la cre demeure tout de même le principal
outil de pression aujourd'hui sur le
pouvoir algérien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup ont dit pour le régime
s'étaient pas béni cette pandémie a
permis d'arrêter un mouvement une
puissance absolument inédite un
mouvement populaire qui avait bouleversé
qui remuait l'ensemble du pays
même si les manifestations de masse ont
été stoppés par l'écrivain qui eux-mêmes
pour des raisons sanitaires les gens ont
continué de manifester et cela fait à
peu près cinq six mois que dans des
petites villes des manifestations
continuent à se donner
il est certain qu'il ya une migration du
crack dans la rue vers les réseaux
sociaux mais en même temps les comités
de quartier qui existent et les comités
de villages tous les gens qui se
reconnaissent comme pierre lac liste
dans un même quartier tout ça à perdurer
les gens continuent à se concerter a
essayé d'organiser des choses ensemble à
réfléchir sur une sortie de crise
[Musique]
s'en aille il dégage toute cette
nomenclature a le vrai pouvoir des
militaires et puis sa façade civile que
tous ces gens là disparaissent
c'était la première revendication
exprimée dès février 2019
et puis l'autre revendication bien
entendu qui est toujours présent
totalement prégnante et qui mobilise les
gens c'est il faut que l'algérie
devienne un pays démocratique et c'est
là que c'est aussi la convergence d'un
certain nombre de mouvements sociaux
syndicaux de revendications de la
massivité dont delà de caractère berder
de l'identité algérienne
le mouvement des femmes des féministes
le mouvement des jeunes chômeurs le
gouvernement de boon n'a pas non plus
apporté de réponse et de transformation
majeure à ce que dénonce et fiona que
ton qu'effectivement les demandes sont
toujours sur la table
ce qu'on voit depuis un mois ou deux je
dirais c'est qu'il ya de plus en plus de
militants qui ont été arrêtés
manifestants qui ont été arrêtées et qui
font l'objet de dons les juges décident
que finalement non hills a fait l'objet
de non lieu ils sont libérés et puis
certains fonds sont au contraire font
l'objet de deux peines pénales très très
lourde
un an deux ans trois ans de prison ça
c'est le jeu du régime effectivement
pour essayer d'isoler qu'un tout petit
nombre de personnes en dix ans c'est eux
les vrais opposants comme si les zones
n'existait pas de cette répression là
elle essaie de façonner de faire émerger
en quelque sorte des figures de position
justement ça ne marche pas ça ne marche
pas parce que les gens la majorité
l'immense majorité des algériens savent
que dès qu'il ya des leaders qui
apparaissent ils vont être soit
violemment et férocement réprimée soit
de plus souvent c'est ce qu'on a observé
depuis de longues années depuis
plusieurs décennies même ils vont être
récupérés le régime algérien fait en
sorte que les algériens soient dégoûtés
du politique d'écouté de l'engagement
associatif et c'est vrai que c'est aussi
le firak dans ces manifestations qui
portaient la voie des prisonniers
d'opinion
c'est vrai que leur sort est devenu
compliqué depuis l'arrêt des
manifestations
à
par son ampleur inédite le herald de
90,2 2019 et 2020 était que ce qu'on
peut appeler une révolution il a
absolument aucun doute inachevé elle a
été fauchée d'une certaine façon dans
son expression la plus évidente par la
pandémie
ça peut pas dire qu'elle a été éradiquée
en aucune façon si jamais les taux de la
pandémie se desserre un peu ce qu'il
faut souhaiter bien entendu ça reprendra
de façon absolument certaine 1 c'est le
peuple qui est du côté des gagnants est
pas le régime
il est évident qu'un mouvement tel que
celui-là a essaimé en dehors du champ
des deux manifestations dans la société
algérienne en terme de débats en termes
de valeur et aussi sur une influence en
fait se perpétue tant que les problèmes
qu'il a dénoncés sont présents
l'avenir du fenac dépend vraiment de
deux choses distinctes c'est bien
évidemment les espaces de négociation
que le pouvoir est prête à ouvrir et là
je crois que une
n'y aura pas de 2 d'ici là sans pression
internationale ni pression de la rue
l'ouverture d'un espace et l'avenir du
rivage dépendra également de la capacité
des algériens à continuer à accepter
l'incurie de la société algérienne des
institutions d'une situation sanitaire
et économique qui va en se dégradant et
là effectivement il y a encore matière
pour le chirac a mobilisé et il ya
donner de l'espérance aux algériens en
termes de changements possibles et de
sortie de crise possible